hello everyone and welcome back to the
knockouts of the ftx crypto cup we are
continuing with the second match between
magnus carlsen and hikaru nakamura if
you've been following yesterday the game
uh well the match ended in a draw
uh both of them won both of their games
with the white pieces it was a pretty
pretty fun day
but now this one is really really
spectacular i'm sure you're going to
enjoy it so
without further ado let's check it out a
lot of things to cover as a lot of
things
have happened so magnus with the white
pieces again
opens with e4 and again we are going to
have
uh well the joko piano we have knight to
f6
uh knight to f3 knight c6 bishop to c4
we have bishop to c5 and now
uh yes now magnus castle i'm pretty sure
he's saving all the good stuff for you
know maybe semi-finals or the finals uh
so here he castles we have knight to f6
and now d3 uh we have castles by hikaru
rook to e1 and now if you remember if
you've been following the channel for
quite some time
i always mentioned that knight to g4
isn't really doing anything for black
because
uh well if the knight comes here then
you can simply defend
this with rook to e2 and then kick away
the knight but this is exactly what he
car
plays so he's trying to mix things up
here so magnus does go rook to e2
defense is pawn and next he's going to
kick away the knight with h3
we have king to h8 by hikaru getting
away from this diagonal preparing f5 and
now
h3 and now hikaru of course goes for the
sharpest move possible and that is f5
f5 is basically the only good move uh
for black here because that's why you
play this line with knight to g4
point is that if white gets greedy and
goes after the knight
then black will most likely win this
game for example captures the knight
here
the knight has to move somewhere you can
see there's incredible pressure here on
the f2 pawn then you can
play g3 the pawn cannot capture and this
is just terrible for white
if you go knight f3 if you try to save
your piece then even
rook captures on f3 g captures and queen
h4 and now you're getting checkmated
so this is uh this is not hikaru's plan
of course he car knows that magnus will
not fall for this but
uh you know he maybe studied this a
little bit more uh
specifically for this match so this is
where he's gonna look for his chances
uh magnus played bishop to g5 which is
the most common move here
there is one notable game uh wesley so
versus anish giri
from the 2016 bilbao masters where uh
wesley played knight the c3 and he
defeated
giri with this move but here like i said
we have bishop to g5 attacking the queen
uh and now knight back to f6 uh the
knight now just defends and now we
continue with knight to c3
and the d6 so just like nothing happened
but by playing this knight to g4 move he
car was
able to sneak in this f5 move and now uh
his rook will
well very soon have a nice semi-open f
file to use for attack
knight to d5 by magnus now f captures an
e4d captures and now bishop to e6 here
we have a
a couple of trades knight captures on f6
and now
there is a game where bishop captures
and c4 was played but here we have g
captures on f6 by hikaru and it is now
already as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game
and it seems that this is what hikaru
prepared now he's going to use the g
file for attack
and let's see how magnus deals with his
magnus first eliminates the light square
bishop
uh we have f capture sun g5 and now c3
nicely controlling this knight so the
knight cannot jump jump into the game
uh and now you also uh well if need you
have queen b3 queen a4 all depends on
what what black plays
uh we have queen to f6 by hikaru going
after the bishop here
and magnus retreats it we have knight to
e7 now and now uh you can see that
hikaru's position
is very very solid he's planning to
bring the knight to g6 from there the
knight can come to h4 to f4
depending on what white plays but he has
a lot of good moves and
his plan is very simple he's probably
going to move this rook here bring this
rook to f8 or maybe he can even triple
up here on the f file
and the magnus spent some seven minutes
for his next move as it's not all that
clear
what to do he played queen to d2 and now
he's going for the g5 pawn
and he carl just defended with rook to
g8 so this rook can now come to f8
uh we have b4 by magnus uh
attacking this bishop here bishop back
to b6 and now a4
of course playing a5 would be the dream
for white uh
not uh even even if you don't win the
bishop even if
c6 was already played but you just want
to get the dark square bishop away from
this diagonal
of course hikaru will not allow this he
plays a5 and now queen to a2 by magnus
magnus knows that his
his position uh isn't all that
impressive and he's very much low on
time he has some four and a half minutes
on the clock whereas hikaru has almost
11 minutes on the clock
and now he wants to play queen to e6 and
get uh maybe trade queens and
well try and survive this attack uh
hikaru just plays queen to g6
we have queen to e6 by magnus and now
hikaru goes
queen to g7 here hikaru uh misses a
bit of a uh well uh
a very nice move here with h5
because now uh after playing h5 the
bishop
doesn't really have any good squares you
could go to f5 but only then we move uh
the queen to g7 in black's position is
fine and the problem with
trading here is that if you capture on
h5 now then knight f4 just uh wins
material as your bishop and
rook and e2 are under attack so maybe a
slight improvement here
but okay queen to g7 by hikaru uh we
have b
captures on a5 uh bishop characters now
for the moment the bishop leaves this
diagonal
and rook to b1 going after this pawn
here
so now while you could bring the bishop
back how just goes
rook to a7 uh defending the pawn like
this and now uh keeping
the bishop here to target the c3 pawn
we have queen to c4 defending the pawn
and now queen to g6 so what do you play
here now the queen again guards the h5
square and the
car wants the bush h5 uh and there is
okay magnus i'm not gonna tell you what
magnus played here because there is a
really really awesome move here
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find a really cool idea for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
finding rook to b5 because this is what
magnus played however there is a much
nicer move and that is knight to d4
knight to d4 is simply a beautiful move
because that now you can shift your
knights to f5 and you've pretty much
solved all of your problems
there's nothing uh there's nothing good
happening here for black
and the other thing is if the knight is
captured well then look at this
this is very unfortunate for black we're
just gonna capture on d4
deliver check and after queen g7 we're
gonna pick up the rook on a7
so this was in the position
congratulations to everyone who found it
uh as uh well obviously not an easy move
to spot in a rapid game so here rook to
b5 by magnus
now with a lot of pressure on the e file
magnus might be thinking about
sacrificing a piece here to open up this
diagonal
and hikaru goes for c6 here he
even forces this to happen or he just
says
okay go back with the rook and the
problem is okay maybe rook captures it
would be a bit too aggressive
yes you attack the queen but after queen
f6 you don't really have a good
follow-up
if knight f7 check we just attacked the
knight twice and that's it
black just wins so magnus decided to go
for the other trade he played knight
captures on e5 giving up the knight for
two central pawns
uh pong captures and now rook captures
on e5 but the rook captures on e5 is not
the most correct way to play this uh
again magnus misses
uh a slightly better idea which is to
just play
instead of rook capture see rook
captures on a5 and
now after rook captures an a5 just queen
before with a double attack here
and now after the rule goes back now we
capture on e7
and then we continue playing this so now
white's position is is much better
uh but here after rook captures an e5
well he just gives hikaru
a bit too much we have rook to d8 and
now hikaru says uh you're welcome to
to take my knight uh the problem is if
magnus does this
rook captures on e7 then we have this
check and after king to h2
uh queen to uh d6 is just a game over
for white as you blunder a rook here
so it's uh never never a good idea to
try and tackle hikaru
when it comes to tactics so here we have
rooked at e6 by magnus attacking the
queen but just queen to g7 now the
knight is nicely defended
uh and the magnus wants to eliminate all
of his problems along the dark squares
so now he simply plays g3 so now if this
rook ever comes here you can simply move
the king
and you're gonna be very safe here and
uh well that's only one of the problems
for magnus his position is worse
but he's also down to 22 seconds on the
clock whereas hikaru has over six
minutes
and here hikaru just plays rook a back
to a8 he says all right
you use your 20 seconds as as well as
you can
i'm just going to improve my position
slowly but surely
we have kinked the g2 by magnus now
knight g6 now again
this knight is uh controlling a lot of
squares here g3 has been played so these
two squares have been taken care of
uh but uh you know uh you you have to
play something we have
e5 by magnus uh now this is a very
dangerous pass pawn
but hikaru immediately attacks it with
bishop to c7 and now there's a triple
attack on the pawn
uh not much hope of defending it so here
magnus has to give it up he plays bishop
to f5
but now hikaru just grabs it he didn't
even think about it for all that much
maybe 10 seconds he wants to
uh force magnus to really waste his time
so here magnus finds queen to b4 and
it's a very nice move
not only attacking the b7 pawn but also
rook to e7 is coming and then you might
really have some problems because the
bishop covers h7
also the dark square bishop would be
attacked so hikaru cannot allow this he
plays rook to f8 now
ready to block this rook with rook to f7
magnus goes for it and now rook to f7 uh
magnus now grabs on b7
attacks this rook uh but hikaru just
doubles up
nicely on the f file magnus trades once
we have captures captures
or rather queen captured on f7 and now
comes
bishop back to e4 the bishop is under
attack so bishop here goes after this
pawn
and now if magnus eliminates this pawn
then okay he has two pass pawns uh for
for the piece so
this again uh could become playable but
now he carves says all right let's start
the attack he pushes h5 now h4 is coming
and if the position opens up then that's
pretty much all there is to say about
this game
magnus says all right i have nothing
better i have to eliminate the pawn
and hope for the best hikaru now goes
queen to c4
with a double attack on the bishop here
but also just ready to eliminate one of
the past pawns so here
bishop to b5 and now comes queen
captures on c3
and magnus centralizes with queen to e4
so again
uh how do you how do you play this with
black well he carry plays queen to c5
now
you will not be able to start advancing
your pawn even if the bishop wasn't
defending now the bishop would be
hanging
also there's a lot of pressure here on
the f2 pawn and still hikari is just
waiting for the perfect moment to push
that pawn to h4
we have rooked the c2 by magnus
attacking the queen now comes queen to
d6
now what you play here magnus goes
bishop back to e2
and now there's really not all that much
for magnus to do here
uh there was one move here that you kind
of could play but it's uh
i mean it's such an ugly move to play
queen to b7 this kind of allows you to
prolong the game
and now if you play something like let's
say bishop to b6 put pressure on this
pawn now you can maybe do a rook lift
with rook here but it's uh
not something you you find in a in a
rapid game and black is still better
here of course but it's a one way to
fight now maybe you can harass the black
king and
maybe maybe good things will happen but
okay after queen to the sixth bishop
back to e2 was played by magnus but now
uh we have
h4 finally h4 is on the board uh magnus
plays g
captures and now comes knight to g6 now
the knight again threatening to come
here to come here and also there's queen
to h2
king f1 and queen to h1 uh okay uh
h1 for the moment covered by the by the
white queen but still you do not want to
allow this because for example checking
if one and then the queen
can capture on f2 with checkmate because
the bishop now covers this pawn so here
we have king the
f1 not allowing this to come with check
and the bishop back to b6 again he
carved threatening to pick up the f2
pawn
bishop to f3 defending and here uh
well you wanna make sure you don't make
the mistake of capturing an h4 although
it looks like a really awesome move
uh it completely blunders the game
because rook c6 and that's it the queen
is under attack
and there's nothing to play here it once
the queen moves let's say you want to
guard the bishop
it's just a very nice rook h6 czech king
here and queen to h7 checkmate
so hikaru has to be extremely precise
here and he is he plays
knight to e5 uh we have rook to d2
attacking the queen here uh and now
comes queen to c5
uh the thing is you don't want to
capture this rook it's not a free rook
if you capture the rook then queen
captures here and now
black is again in big trouble this comes
with check it doesn't matter what you
play bishop d5
checking h7 queen to e7 with check and
that's
it let's say here h5 check and uh
whatever you do you're getting
checkmated a nice one is king captures
and queen to h7 checkmate because the
pawn covers the g4 square
so instead after rook to d2 hikaru just
improves further with
queen to c5 and here magnus goes to rook
to c2 continues harassing hikaru's queen
but now hikaru does what hikaru does
best
and you might also so feel free to pause
the video and win this game
for hikaru in the coolest way possible
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh
of course going for the for the move uh
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's of course
knight captures on f3 a beautiful
really really temporary queen sacrifice
but you're gonna win the queen right
back because
there's this knight to d2 check a
beautiful fork and there's nothing
better for magnus he has to capture the
queen
knights to d2 with check for forking the
king and the queen
king e2 and now we pick up this uh piece
here
uh and now magnus only has a rook and he
has a rook a bishop and the knight but
magnus still has the past a pawn and
he's gonna do his best to
to to maybe somehow get a draw here so
here
bishop captures an f2 hikaru continues
happily winning pieces
uh pawns we have h captures knight
captures and now
a5 magnus starts pushing his pass pawn
knights the e4 and now king d3 uh we
have knight to c5 check
king to c4 and not knight to b7
attacking the pawn here
uh we have rooked the h6 by magnus king
g7 now rook h5 defending the spawn
uh but uh it's uh of little use we have
rooked the a8
attacking the pawn twice now magnus
plays rook to f5 he attacks the bishop
here but hikaru instantly plays it and i
know you guys all see it
of course knight to d6 even magnus
isn't immune to falling for for a nice
fork here and there
but it happens when there are too many
threats to perry you will fall for one
of them
whether it's just a past pawn or a nice
fork an ice cube or a nice
whatever uh you know that the position
simply deteriorates uh onto itself and
there's nothing you can do so after
knight to d6 it was in this position
that magnus carlsen resigned the game
and game one again goes to hikaru so now
it's up to magnus to bounce back we'll
see what happens
as the game two is already underway so
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
it uh we'll see we'll see
if the action will continue this
fiercely i would like to thank roberto
gomez
uh sean ellis uh ryan yaglovsky
andy arden
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice event
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens uh
in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day